what's up guys
lunch money time bang bang while while
she's trying to get rich let's let's
just try to get her lunch money right
i'm here with paulina she's got i don't
even know what on
but i love it today is monday we got
that trillionaire energy i slept 11 and
a half hours last night
bang bang bang bang bang how how much
did you sleep the night before
oh we ain't gonna talk about all that
don't worry i had a par
t on saturday at 5 00 a.m he got mad at
me
for ending the party early we had like
four people over
i ain't mad at 5am hey get you a man who
can party way into the early morning
hours and also can sleep 11 and a half
hours
bang bang don't forget block flies now
sponsor of lunch money go get a block by
account block five dot com slash pomp
eight point six percent ap wide an
interest bearing account
bitcoins popping block fives popping go
get an account eight point six percent
apy an interest bearing account
blockfy.com
pomp all right what's up spacex
launched four astronauts to the
international space station on sunday
on the first full-fledged taxi flight
for nasa
by a private company the falcon rocket
thundered into the
night from the kennedy space center with
three americans and one
japanese astronaut so the commander
commander mike hopkins
right before liftoff he said by working
together through these difficult times
you've inspired the nation the world and
in no small part the name of this
incredible vehicle
resilience and he said once reaching
orbit
he radioed that was one heck of a ride
that's something i would say
not one not two not three
four that's the nba reference for all of
you sitting at home elon did this while
having coven
maybe well he well we don't know if he
hasn't he said he most likely had a
moderate case
whatever uh spacex if you hate spacex
you're a loser
don't call the people losers no only the
people who hate spacex how do you hate a
company
that is literally 20 years ago a man
said you know what
i think that we should launch rockets
and then have the rockets come back and
land on earth
and when we do that then we can reuse
the rocket to drastically reduce the
cost of space travel
and therefore we can go further and go
do things that we couldn't previously do
it's amazing and then he went and
actually built it and not only is he
landing the rockets back
on earth he's landing the rockets in the
ocean
on drone ships get you some innovation
okay and one more fun fact
nasa added a surprise fifth passenger
a baby yoda a plush baby yoda toy also
known as a zero gravity indicator
typically a soft small object that is
allowed to float free in the spacecraft
cabin
to provide a simple but effective
confirmation of when it when it passes
into the phase
of a space flight where earth's gravity
no longer holds
holds i can't say that word holds
significant sway
next topic we're going to mars there's a
baby yoda up in there
we're going to mars baby yoda the other
day one of his friends called and was
like
tesla's going to saturn and i was like
i think you're confused i don't think
saturn's in the picture and i don't
think tesla's going
anywhere in space but yeah man tesla's
going to saturn sure
instacart has picked goldman sachs to
lead its ipo
which could come early next year and
value the u.s grocery delivery app
at around 30 billion dollars that's
three zero
dollar sign three zero how much revenue
are they doing does it say they last
they raised 200 million dollars last
month at a 17.7 billion
valuation so that would only be a little
less than double how much revenue i
don't think the revenue is public yet no
revenue but
it was last valued at 17.7 so that's it
they have no financial information at
all in there
i don't think the ipo go down go down
hold on quick quick quick down right
there whoa
up up up right last launched in 2012
it's led by the co-founders
their volume has surged as much as 500
percent this year that doesn't tell us
because it could have been a dollar 500
from a dollar ain't that much
okay no problem i'm invested in one of
their competitors
and it's doing well if you would like to
order online groceries
you should go to imperfect foods way
better and it's better for the planet
too
go ahead sending teslas to saturn that's
not
good for the planet maybe another planet
okay 18 months ago uber's self-driving
car unit uber advanced technologies
group
was valued at 7.25 billion dollars
following a one billion dollar
investment from toyota i
remember writing about this uh from
toyota denzo and softbank's vision fund
now it's up for sale in a competing
autonomous vehicle tech startup is in
talks with uber
to buy it aurora innovation well let me
just grab my phone because it keeps
beeping
uh self-driving cars are gonna be
pervasive everywhere
you're literally the streets of new york
at some point in the next i don't know
10 years 20 years
every single car is going to be driving
itself it's literally going to be an
archaic view of the world to think that
humans got in the car behind the wheel
and we counted on
idiotic humans to drive and not crash
into each other idiotic humans
and wait till they figure out how to
make the autonomous cars
go fast when they're flying down the
street at 80 miles an hour
because all of a sudden there's a
city-wide system
and you can get places much faster
that's what i'm here for
all right so you know how pfizer
developed events like high-speed rails
but high-speed cars you just love making
that noise
you know go ahead
it's the same thing if you're a kid at
home
let me see you do it i think nice all
right good job kids
all right barney um so you know how
pfizer
uh developed a vaccine that they claim
is 90 effective
well now moderna which is another
company
they developed a vaccine claiming that
they are 94.5 percent effective against
coronavirus
making it the second vaccine in the us
to have a stunningly high success rate
are we just gonna be like picking like
are people gonna be picking vaccines
like how do you know
i'm suspicious all right the vaccine
innovation is suspicious to me all right
how do these
people all work for so long they can't
come up with vaccines for all these
drugs
this one pops up and it's like six
months later i got ninety percent
i got ninety two percent i'm russia i
got ninety four percent i'm madonna
and wait what yeah where the hell did
russia what y'all been doing
well in when darren has 15 000 study
participants were given a placebo which
is a shot of saline that has no effect
over several months ninety percent of
them developed cova 19 with 11
developing severe forms of the disease
god imagine volunteering then you get
coveted then you get really sick
another fifteen thousand were given the
vaccine and only five of them
developed corporate night you're telling
me if i get the vaccine i could still
get covid
well yeah so because it's not 100
effective obviously
so you tell me what number if it was 50
effective would people take it if you
had a 50 50 shot hey you're going to get
the
background i think that's regular yeah i
think flu vaccine's like 60 or 70
but like it's pretty crazy to think
about if this ends up being like 60 70
effective after all the clinical trials
i don't know we're gonna see
good news is the stock market loves
vaccines vaccines get announced
the stock market says
all right she's over it this is a very
confusing story
so there's a pigeon named new kim it's a
two-year-old female pigeon
that was put up for auction for just 200
euros
but was bought by a bidder from china
for a record amount of
1.9 million dollars almost two million
dollars
this is a racing pigeon yes yes yes
this is a racing piece she's right i'm
wrong this is a racing pigeon
whose family bred and owned it and
they're in shock
at the news my god who is playing
pigeons it's a race it's a racing pigeon
yeah and it's won a bunch of
it was nicknamed oh wait no no this
isn't one no the oh the old record was
held by the lewis hamilton of pigeons
but it was written for those that don't
know lewis hamilton is a f1 racer
so new kim was bought after a bidding
war between two buyers from china
was jason williams involved
[Laughter]
sorry okay where pigeon racing has grown
in popularity in recent years in china
racing pigeons can carry on having
chicks until they're about 10
and it is expected that new kim's new
owners will use her for breeding
new kim 2 million dollar pigeon you know
what i'm about to do i'm about to walk
out on the street there's pigeons
everywhere i gotta find me a couple
pigeons
we'll have a pigeon a little breeding
ground over here
and i'm gonna start selling them if you
want a pigeon i got pigeons if you want
a fast pigeon i got fast pigeons you
want a fat pigeon i got fat pigeons
whatever you need i got it the pigeons
are right there
a fat pigeon owner obviously okay what's
the
question for ask lunch money ask lunch
money use
ask lm in the comments if you want to be
answered it comes from
ritwik nanda kumar um question to pomp
what has been your worst investment in
terms of bad idea investments
slash losses from an investment uh
you go first all right question of pimp
what is the worst characteristic
and two best characteristics about
anthony
she gonna lie why go ahead the worst
characteristic
oh you're perfect you have no vanguard
i'm kidding um
the what is the worst i don't okay so
i'll have
i'll have one that's a double-edged
sword okay
it's a good one and a bad one and then i
need a good one
i'm so good looking that when i walk
down the street ladies be looking at me
yeah um so the good and bad one
is both that anthony is never
in a bad mood facts it's so weird
and it pisses me off obviously because
sometimes i'm in a bad mood and i'm like
how come
how come you just wake up with the
pigeons and you're like oh
cause i slept 11 and a half hours
pigeons chirping everything's great in
the world
pigeons don't sure i was trying to make
a pun
so he's never in a bad mood which is bad
but it's also good because you know like
i never have to be like what's wrong
with you
uh which he does for me all the time and
then the second good
quality is that i've never heard him say
a bad word about anybody even if
i know the person's kind of sketchy he
doesn't say anything bad about them
behind their back if he's gonna say
something he'll tell it to your face but
he'll never say it behind your back
i do do that if i don't like you you'll
know all right
my worst investment uh i'm not gonna say
what company it was but
there's been two or three companies
where i've lost all my money in the
investment
all the money i put into that investment
uh and the founders quit
so those are that's the hardest part to
uh to definitely underwrite is like
if the founder's just gonna give up at
some point um that usually means you're
going to lose your money
uh and then you know his best investment
best early stage investment
facts kidding okay do you have
the only other thing i'll say about good
or bad investment um
is a lot of times i've actually had
what turned out to be great investments
but i sold them too early so over time
i've learned
hey something's going don't be the one
to stop the train
just one time away double down one time
when bitcoin went down
a lot i had to talk him off the ledge of
like you're fine it's gonna go back
up yeah march 18th i think it was on
march 12th something like that this year
when it dropped 50
in the day your boy was not having a
very good feeling in his stomach i was
like how low is this going to go and i
kept how low can you
i kept uh guilt buying every time i
would drop a little bit i'll buy a
little more but uh
it didn't feel so hot and plain was like
it'll go back up and i was like
did it did it go back up yeah yeah all
right
sorry all right that's it for lunch
money today
i'm gonna go get me some pigeons see you
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends